la locura mundialista Ya está presente
en Qatar un grupo de cuatro amigos
argentinos aventuró a recorrer 10.000
kilómetros desde Sudáfrica hasta Qatar
todo con un solo objetivo apoyar a su
selección doblemente mundialista
el Cuarteto argentino realizó un
recorrido de 177 días pedaleando casi
unos seis meses hasta llegar a un
desafío mayor fue el último que fue
cruzar el desierto de Arabia Saudita
tengo que hacer 2000 kilómetros
hicimos más o menos 150 kilómetros por
día y era levantarse comer algo y
desayunar salía de rutas además de
realizar este arduo recorrido el equipo
de toda pedal buscaba romper los
estereotipos sobre las personas de los
países por los que pasaban mientras
grababan imágenes para realizar un
documental Este es el último de una
serie de viajes de larga distancia que
los ciclistas han realizado para asistir
a importantes eventos deportivos como
los Juegos Olímpicos de Río 2016 y el
mundial de Rusia 2018 una aventura
increíble más que una aventura fue una
una escuela de vida pues impresionante
todas las cosas que hemos vivido todavía
no no procesamos no nos damos cuenta no
dimensionamos de de lo que hemos logrado
el equipo utilizó las redes sociales
para narrar su recorrido diario y pedir
ayudas a sus seguidores al llegar a doha
cientos de aficionados los esperaban
para animar su último tramo mientras el
comité de organización y legado de la
FIFA les daba la bienvenida después de
recorrer 10.000 kilómetros en bicicleta
cruzando África y medio oriente los
argentinos de todo a pedal llegaron a
Qatar Para apoyar a su elección en la
copa del mundo ahora el equipo de
ciclista se prepara para ver el debut de
su selección contra Arabia Saudita el 22
de noviembre en luz hay el Stadium
[Música]